[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good morning, everyone.
It's wonderful to see you.
I am Tomiko Brown-Nagin, the
dean of the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study here
at Harvard University.
Welcome to our annual gender
conference, focused this year
on the intersection of
gender and communication
beyond spoken words.
Last night, we kicked
off our conference
with an exploration
of communication
through the lens
of drag culture.
It was quite a great evening.
If you couldn't
join us, I encourage
you to watch the recording
of that evening that'll
be posted online.
Today, we consider the
aesthetics of communication
through topics as diverse
as tattoos, perfume,
animal behavior, robots,
sign language, and dance.
The program will engage
our minds and senses.
And I expect it'll
reveal aspects
of unspoken communication
that many of us
might not have
considered before.
Interdisciplinarity
is the very core
of what we do here at Radcliffe,
and it permeates every session
of this convening.
As we engage today,
I hope you'll
keep in mind yesterday
evening's discussion
and consider how the examples of
bodily communication we explore
relate to issues of
equity, opportunity,
and inclusion, another
core element of Radcliffe's
identity.
It's still a reality that
many individuals are demeaned,
devalued, and discriminated
against because of how they
express their gender
identity and how
others perceive it are for
pushing against gender norms.
This past fall, a public
library system in Louisiana
prohibited a story
hour event because it
would feature drag queens
reading children's books.
Similar reading programs
exist across the country,
including here in the
Cambridge-Boston area.
And so, too, do efforts
to censor drag performers,
whether in libraries,
onstage, or elsewhere.
In our nation's schools,
students are frequently
disciplined because
their appearance
violates dress codes that hinge
on traditional gender norms.
And research shows
that these dress codes
are disproportionately enforced
against black girls, who
tend to be perceived by
adults as less innocent, more
adult-like, and more sexual as
compared to their white peers.
Transgender and
gender-nonconforming
individuals experience
mistreatment, discrimination,
and even violence at
particularly alarming rates.
A staggering 83% of
transgender youth
and 69% of gender-nonconforming
youth in grades 6 through 12
report being bullied
or harassed at school.
I mention these examples because
they illustrate the importance
of thinking intersectionally.
Bodily communication
and how others perceive
that communication varies
in meaningful ways,
not only across
gender but also as
to race, sexual orientation,
class, ability, nationality,
and so much more.
This is something to keep
in the back of our minds
today as we dive into
this illuminating
conversation focused on the
aesthetics of communication.
In a moment, I'll
turn things over
to my colleague, Professor
Shigehisa Kuriyama,
who conceptualized
this conference
and who will introduce
today's program.
Hisa is the faculty director
of the humanities at Radcliffe
and the Reischauer
Institute Professor
of Cultural History in the
faculty of arts and sciences
here at Harvard.
But first, let me express
my thanks to everyone who's
made this convening possible.
I'm very grateful to Hisa
and to all of our speakers,
moderators, and performers.
Let me also thank Rebecca
Wassarman, executive director
of academic ventures here at
Radcliffe, Jessica Viklund,
director of events, and the
entire ventures and events
teams.
I also want to recognize members
of the Radcliffe Institute
Leadership Society and all of
our dedicated annual donors.
Radcliffe's lectures,
conferences, exhibitions,
and collections
are free and open
to the public because of
your generous support.
Thank you.
And finally, thanks to
all of you in the audience
for joining us.
We're happy to have you here.
With that, please join me in
warmly welcoming Hisa Kuriyama.
Hisa.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good morning.
- Ba.
Ba.
[LAUGHTER]
- These two examples--
I only have three minutes.
So these two examples are
used to illustrate the two
key points that I'd like you to
take away from my introduction.
One is there are illustrations
of how much communication
occurs beyond what's
explicitly given.
If I just said good
morning, then you'd
just take it as something
to be listened to.
If I say good morning
a different way,
then you know to answer.
Similarly, with--
let's try this.
Ba.
- Ba Ba.
[LAUGHTER]
- That's the other aspect
that you will have to think.
So the first point
is really about
how there's so much more
communicated than usually
we just explicitly express.
The second important
point, I think,
about particularly
this conference
is that we really do conceive
of this as a participatory kind
of event.
I think many of the speakers
will engage you directly.
But even if you're
just listening,
I'd like you to listen actively.
There'll be a question period
for each of the panels.
And as you listen, think
about the questions
not only that you want
to ask, which, of course,
is important, but also what
you think the speaker wants
to speak more about.
We have a fantastic, really,
an all-star cast of speakers.
They only have a very short
period of time to speak.
And if you give
them an opportunity
to elaborate on
something that they
want to speak but they don't
have the time to speak,
then they'll be
eternally grateful.
So with that, let
me proceed directly
to our first speaker, who
will provide some framing
for the idea of communication.
And this is Professor
John Durham Peters,
who is the María Rosa--
Meno-cul?
- Menocal.
- --Menocal Professor of English
and professor of film and media
studies at Yale University.
He's the author of many
books, but the book
I'd like to draw your
attention to in particular
is Speaking into the Air--
A History of the Idea of
Communication, because this
is actually the book which--
and it's a book I
highly recommend.
It's the book that
gave me, actually,
the idea for this conference.
So it's with tremendous delight
that I welcome Professor Peters
to give the framing remarks.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
My dear fellow embodied
beings, good morning.
Today is the 10th birthday
of my oldest granddaughter,
Libby Anne Lambert Peters.
And this is the way that I met
Libby, as an ultrasound image.
You can kind of
see her face there.
But the first thing I knew
about Libby was her gender.
And her gender preceded her.
Her gender goes with her.
Her gender is pervasive
in all kinds of ways.
Obviously, gender saturates our
world, our bodies, and the ways
that we interact, the ways that
grandfathers and granddaughters
interact.
I haven't talked with her
yet today, but I plan to.
The drag performance last
night kept making me think--
this might sound strange--
of the aesthetic theory of
the great and gnarly thinker
Theodor Adorno, who might
actually have liked drag.
He'd like circus acts and
the burlesque, for sure.
For him, aesthetics was the
claim of an artful justice
in a broken world.
Gender, a topic otherwise
so pervasive and so painful,
one that is so weighty
and has so much at stake,
that's so wonderful
and so on omnipresent,
in drag is briefly transfigured
into an art, a florid zone
of freedom, choice, and play.
As Adorno somewhere said,
"In a perfect society,
the only thing
that would survive
the injury of the
difference between the sexes
is the happiness that
it makes possible."
Another sense of
aesthetics is to emphasize
embodied sensation.
Here comes the
obligatory etymology.
[GREEK] in ancient
Greek means "I sense."
So the very notion
of aesthetics has
to do with embodied concrete
sensation-- eyes, ears,
tactility, taste,
kinesthetic, all the ways
that we exist in the world.
So aesthetics-- I am very
happy that that's our theme--
is much better than
epistemology when
we talk about communication.
The history of the
term "communication--"
it's a very odd
history because it
tends to be medium
neutral or medium hostile.
That is that successful
communication was long
understood as being the
disappearance of the medium
and a kind of demure
self-sacrifice in which
some precious, elusive
substance shines through,
such as mind or meaning.
Now, this sense of
communication we
get from an older sense
of the term [GREEK],,
or transmission, really,
of some kind of element
through a medium, such as glass.
The element is often something
like electricity, magnetism,
or ether.
So these physical processes
which allow for connection
across distance of
precious substances
came to refer to the
way that minds interact
in the philosophy of John
Locke in the Essay Concerning
Human Understanding
of 1690 in which he
talked about the
communication of ideas.
Locke gave us this
eternal problem
when we think about
communication of epistemology,
is how do you know what's
in the other's head?
How do you get your ideas
in the other person's head?
This notion of
communication was reinforced
in the 19th century
when electricity became
the means of connecting people,
thanks to the telegraph,
telephone, phonograph,
also via fast mails.
These were
ghost-multiplying media,
as Franz Kafka memorably put it.
Now, of course we all depend
upon accurate transmission.
That's obviously important.
But there's a lot of
conceptual collateral damage.
If a term whose chief
value is accuracy
comes to describe the human
interaction in general,
moving a signal is
not the same as doing
the hard work of
inhabiting a common space
or working together to
create mutual understanding.
And the term "communication"
took on this expansive sense--
again, a celebration on my
part of aesthetics rather than
epistemology.
An even weirder
part of the history
is this term "nonverbal
communication,"
which first seems to have
been used in the 1950s--
that's very late-- by the
Swiss-American psychiatrist
Jurgen Ruesch in a book.
Now, of course, notions
of nonverbal communication
were found among
ethologists, including
Charles Darwin, before.
And it's funny because
nonverbal is defined negatively
as everything
which is not words,
but I think this is such
a constricted conception,
because everything
that connects us
with embodiment
and with the cosmos
somehow gets turned into
something we call nonverbal,
which is extremely limited.
Nonetheless, the virtue
of the term "nonverbal"
was to reconnect our many
modes of mutual interaction
with our embodiment.
So the question
of the aesthetics
of our embedded sociability
is obviously urgent in a time
when our everyday interaction
in a digital world
has all of us playing
Turing games, that is,
trying to persuade
others that we
are human with no other
medium than a keyboard.
When I talk to my
granddaughter today,
I hope we can
FaceTime, not text.
But who's a bot, and who's not?
This is a question that I can't
always tell the answer for,
especially when I'm
looking in the mirror.
But we find ourselves
embedded and diffused
in our various modes of being
in the world with other people.
And embodiment
always has a gender.
The voice, for my money,
is one of the most
interesting and
stubborn gender markers,
as we might talk about.
There are very few female
contrabasses, very few
male sopranos,
unless they've been
doctored so that they don't have
testosterone, they're castrati.
So what I've done so far
in this very brief talk
is follow a strategy
of de-naturalization
by looking at the
history of words
to show how things could
have been otherwise.
And indeed, in gender-critical
work for the past 50 years,
de-naturalization has been
one of the major strategies,
and justly so, because to
say that gender is natural
can have obvious toxic
ideological side effects.
Nature has been conceived in
the realm of gender studies
as culture in
disguise, as an enemy
or an untrustworthy
breeding ground of ideology.
So then we have this
very deep suspicion
of nature talk with regard
to gender and, of course,
with regard to race,
ethnicity, sexuality,
and other modes of
human difference.
We like to insist upon
gender as fluid, constructed,
performative.
Now, they say climate
is what you expect.
Weather is what you get.
That's a handy breakdown.
I'd suggest something similar.
Sex is the naked body.
Gender is the dressed body.
I think this is a more robust
distinction than biology
and culture because
of the stubborn way
that biology and culture mingle
in the domain of embodiment,
such as Iris Marion Young's
famous, fabulous essay
on throwing like a girl
from 1978 in which she shows
that she doesn't
think that women have
inferior ballistic capacities
or anatomy compared with men,
but in a patriarchal culture,
that modes of motility
and movement are actually
built into the musculature,
to the nervous tone, to the gait
such that oppression becomes
genuinely embodied and real.
And so it's hard to
tell where ontology ends
and history begins.
And indeed, in no domain
is the confusion or fusion
of reality and contingency
so clear as in gender.
Gender is both fully real
and fully constructed.
When the drag performers
last night held up signs
announcing in bold letters
"me" on the other side
of a gender-ambiguous
placard, I think
the manifest point
was supposed to be
to celebrate an authentic
kind of homecoming
or therapeutic self acceptance.
But the more obvious and
perhaps even more radical
interpretation was to show
that personal identity is
inseparable from
performance and artifice.
How hard do we want to make
the nature-culture split
in thinking about gender?
This is something I'm
generally puzzled about.
A major development recently
in intellectual life
is a fusion or a meltdown
between STEM fields
and humanities and an interest
on the part of humanists
in reclaiming the
category of nature,
something which humanists,
for a long time,
treated as a dirty word.
On a planet in which
nature is something
that is set apart and
designated as such by humans,
on a planet in which
anthropogenic meddling
with nature is visible
from the sea floor
to the upper atmosphere, when
we think of weather and climate
as profoundly affected
by human habits,
do we want to hold onto such a
hard distinction between nature
and culture?
In any case, what
is nature like?
Nature is infinitely diverse--
well, not infinitely,
because it's
constrained by environments
and all kinds of other things,
by niches and
their construction.
Wait for my
colleague, Rick Prum,
to tell you about
bird ornaments.
What a crazy quilt
of variations.
Nature is profligate
with variation.
So I think I can actually
feel comfortable in saying
gender is natural.
You might want to
fight me on this.
That does not mean
it's fixed or given.
Heck, what is fixed or
given in nature anyway?
What does it mean?
But it does mean that gender
is ubiquitous and meaningful.
Here's another provocation.
And I get the reasons
for the questionings
and deconstructions of binary.
But if we want to celebrate
all the varieties of gender
options, of course the
binary has to be one of them.
You can cut the two interlocking
circles to get squares,
as Hisa did last
night, or you can
cut them to get united hearts.
There are lots of ways
to make such a split.
Maybe our job is
to figure out how
to make the two boxes cozier
and friendlier, kinder,
rather than to abolish
them altogether.
Why have we gotten
used to thinking
that all the
variation in diversity
is on the side of culture,
of social construction,
rather than of nature?
Natural variation can
outstrip anything the wildest
performer can come up with.
Nature is, of course, the
ultimate drag performer.
So let me conclude
by a meditation
on this ultimate mystery of
gender, which I've been trying
to think about and
understand implicitly
all of my embodied life.
And indeed, they
didn't have ultrasounds
before I was born but probably
before my embodied life.
And I can't think of a topic
more pressing, more painful,
more interesting, and more
beautiful than gender.
But I can't say what it is,
and I can't say what it means.
So let us, for a moment, dwell
with the mystery, the mystery
that we are not our own,
that our bodies are not
our own, that the
plasticity of our bodies
has limits, that our bodies are
made out of stardust, out of--
it's a poetic saying,
but it's literally true,
because without the
nucleosynthesis of supernovae,
we would not have the
complicated chemicals that we
need to be organic beings.
Our bodies are connected to
agriculture, to nutrition,
to medicine, to
geography, to history,
to the mating choices
made by our ancestors.
Our bodies are ultimate
hybrids of nature and culture.
And so to celebrate
the mystery, I
want to go to one of
my favorite poets,
who was a first-rate
celebrant of the aesthetics
of embodied communication,
Walt Whitman.
Whitman wrote, "I diffuse
my flesh in eddies,
and drift it in lacy jags--"
could be drag, right?
So he celebrated the many
forms that embodiment can take.
But the thing that made
Whitman an amazing poet
was that he included
within the realm of bodily
being in the world debility
and death and deterioration
and breakdown.
"The translucent mold
of me it shall be you--"
the stench of armpits.
"I keep as delicate
around the bowels
as around the head and heart."
These are all quotes from
Song of Myself so far.
"I resist anything better
than my own diversity."
"And that a kelson of
the creation is love,
and limitless are leaves stiff
or drooping in the fields,
and brown ants in the
little wells beneath them,
and mossy scabs
of the worm fence,
heap'd stones, elder,
mullein, and poke-weed."
One of the remarkable
things about his poetics
is that he's able to infuse such
a mundane, ordinary scene not
of glamorous nature but of
leaves drooping, brown ants,
mossy scabs with a kind
of reverence or holiness.
But Whitman is also aware
of the terror of nature
and the terror of being
in a body, which we know,
whatever the plasticity
of our bodies might be,
is always hurtling
inevitably toward death.
So in his poem "This Compost,"
the opening line is "Something
startles me where I
thought I was safest."
"Something startles me where
I thought I was safest."
And this is what I find
always happens with gender.
Something startles me where
I thought I was safest.
This poem, of course, is about
decomposition and compost.
But it's also about composition,
the poetics of compost,
where in which
composition, compost.
You get it.
I mean, he's riffing on
the poetry of compost.
So let us end with
Whitman, a final line
from Song of Myself,
which I think
applies to our embodied being
because bodies imply gender.
"I and this mystery
here we stand."
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- [INAUDIBLE].
questions?
- Yes.
- OK.
- So Professor Peters
will field questions
on his very provocative talk.
- I wondered if you would
elucidate more about
that idea of if you're
having a spectrum of allowed
but retaining the binary
is one of those elements.
Can you talk a little
bit more about what
that conceptualization
would look like?
- This is a really
difficult thing
to think through because
it's so sensitive
and ticklish and delicate,
because it can feel like you're
stomping on hard work that
people have done to carve out
space for modes of being
which have been historically
stigmatized.
But I think that it's pretty
persistent, as far as I
can tell, that biologically
complementary conspecifics will
find ways of signaling
that gender difference.
And the gender
difference is something
which we're going
to be stuck with
or to celebrate in a
variety of plastic ways
and that it's not
commonsensical and not
true to the complexity of
our gender being in the world
if we want to abolish some
kind of statistical binary
in general.
I'm not saying everybody has
to fit in one box or another
but to recognize that--
well, let's speak
French for a minute.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Gender is a genre.
It's the same word in French.
And if we could think of
gender as genres of being
which are family resemblances--
and I just think that
it's important for us
to be able to think about gender
difference as being something
which we're not--
at least in my own
personal cosmology,
it's not something that I'm
interested in abolishing.
I'm interested in rethinking
it, making it more fair,
more just, more
beautiful, but I'm not
interested in just saying
binaries are only oppressive.
Does that help?
- Can I ask one other question?
- Please, yeah.
Yeah.
- And when you're using gender,
it seemed like it was some--
switching between
biology and expression.
Is that how you're
using the word?
I just wondered how
you conceived of--
- Yeah, see, what
I was trying to say
is that if you have a
conception of gender which
is purely social construction,
that is not true to the way
that gender gets
into our bodies.
I mean, the standard
line was to say
that XY, XX, estrogen,
testosterone,
I mean anatomical
physiology-- that's sex,
but the gender is clothing
performance, gait, voice,
style, dress, shaving,
yeah, which one doesn't
do in the '70s, I think, right?
Yeah, but I don't think you
can rigorously hold to that.
So yes, and obviously
I haven't figured out--
I mean, we're all
trying to figure it out.
- Yeah, thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Thanks.
Yep.
- Hi.
Thank you so much
for your remarks.
In the beginning, you mentioned
the idea of ghostliness.
And I know that
this is a concept
that you speak to much
more in your book Speaking
into the Air.
But I'm wondering
specifically how
you see those concepts of
ghostliness and the ephemeral
relating to gender.
- That is such a
wonderful question.
How do ghosts show up?
Ghosts show up by sound.
And sound and voices are so
interesting because they're
disembodied, and yet,
they always mean that--
the gender and race always
seem to sneak back into voices,
again, in various ways.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
And I'll have to
think about this.
But I think that every
medium reorganizes embodiment
and that embodiment
is always going
to be gendered in
one way or another
so that when you have a
new medium which allows
for people to be in touch--
in touch-- across a
distance that that's
going to produce all kinds
of weird gender ripples,
as it does like with the
history of the telephone
or the history of the radio.
- Thank you.
- Was that close enough?
- Yes.
Thank you.
- OK, thanks.
- Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]